[Music]
well what exactly attracted me to do
architecture is because the fact that
architecture is basically the love of
art at the same time the love of beauty
and pure forms good design is all about
the users the functionality of the
building what is it for and who is it
for neon city is a most interesting
project in the sense that it is
something that I have never done before
so the important thing was to design
building for the shoppers as well as
people who owns a shop inside there now
the ideal that design this was we wanted
something more oriental being a
spiritual community they love red
colours so that's how we selected a ring
right now when you polish gran light
your last a long time after 23 years the
building is as good as new
because it is polished the latest
project which I just completed across
neon City is called 268 and it's an
interesting challenge because the idea
was to be able design a building totally
in glass and be able to appear from
otaru and you can see the goods
displayed in there well Abdullah's are
in same time we always want to face our
children but the only way the face also
is have three cages stacked on top
another
and that other that you use the cables
of pull it together so that he doesn't
twist so therefore I look he formed the
right shape of the glass box then on top
that comes the glass panels so it's a
very modern building and goes to show
that as an architect you're supposed to
be able to do any type of evening and
they may attempt it please do a good job
you can't do I conic buildings but they
must make sure that these buildings are
useful if the building is not useful you
can do anything become the piece of
sculpture to be looked at but not use so
therefore as an architect you're
supposed to be providing for people
because we're always designing for
people never been designing for
ourselves so again you go back to the
user in here and that's what I call good
architecture
[Music]